hello everybody my name is markiplier
and we just hit 25,000 subscribers I
just wanted to take a moment to
reintroduce myself my name is markiplier
but that's just my handle my full name
is Mark Fischbach I'm a biomedical
engineering student from the University
of Cincinnati and I'm introduced hello
everybody
got me to say goodbye hello everybody
and welcome to our thirty thousand
subscriber V la guerre hello everybody
we just hit 40 thousand subscribers
that's an incredible number that's that
that's a big number that he just hit
45,000 subscribers last night it's been
a crazy ride to get here so quickly and
I don't even know how it happened but I
know that you did it we've been getting
about a thousand subscribers a day plus
or minus for the past few weeks and
that's not an exaggeration because we
were just at fifty thousand two weeks
ago it was this channel it's a reason
why I get up in the morning and the
reason why I lose sleep at night because
if I'm not doing anything or talking to
people and I spend a lot more time
talking to people and I'm happy about
that
I'm thinking about the channel almost 24
hours a day I just want to work on it
and I want to make content for you guys
and I want to do this for a long time
and I want to do more I want to do
better videos I want to do bigger things
I want to make my own stuff I believe
that anyone can thank you guys so much
for everything you guys are literally
the best fans in the world I couldn't
ask for like anything more from because
I want to be worthy of your time so
thank you all thank thank you truly from
the bottom of my heart I cannot thank
you enough I want to thank you each
individually but it's sad to see some
things go that come with a smaller
Channel
the benefi potential benefit that
outweighs what there used to be is just
too high you can't escape oh well um if
if you guys have no idea what's going on
right now um I just watched my well not
mine um a thank you video from my fans
from you guys in it was um it's it's it
is probably the greatest present I've
ever gotten thank you guys thank you
guys so much
it took ten months to get the first
hundred thousand subscribers and we got
the next hundred thousand in less than
two you guys are more powerful than you
know you can move mountains if you
wanted to you just got to work together
and I am so grateful for what you've
done to change my life and I know that
together we can work to change the world
the things that we're going to do
together are absolutely incredible I
can't wait for a new month to arrive so
that we can raise charity for someone
else and help someone else in need it's
the greatest feeling in the world to
know that you guys have my back and are
supporting me all the way you're doing
an absolutely incredible job so thank
you so much thank you for 200 thousand
subscribers thank you for
everything that you've done to make me
feel like what I'm doing is right and
I'm pointed in the right direction
because if I'm not I need you guys to
let me know and I need you guys to
always make sure that I stay on that
path and I always maintain that I want
to spread goodwill and help everyone
around me cuz if not I'm doing it for
the wrong reasons so thank you guys so
much every day I'm so grateful when I
get out fit so thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye